topic uh Halo TV
series season two trailer announced adct
has
thoughts oh yeah I have thoughts and I
want people's opinions on this I don't
know how big of a fan were you Mari of
the Halo TV series the first season uh
Curious and what we've seen on going
into the second season there was some
statements from like pretty popular
people in like the the Hollywood
industry that was talking about it too
you know justifying or you know uh
attacking the fact that the mask is if
that's required or not can he show
emotion with the mask I like I can't
remember someone and I'm sure someone in
the chat can uh find it but someone
tweeted it said yeah cuz uh you know
Darth Vader had a whole L had a hard
time showing emotion with this and and
it showed the scene where the emperor
was electrocuting him he said if we only
knew it was shout out to our homie
Stephen Ford he said if we only knew
what Vader was feeling in this moment
but we can't he's got to help you know
he was happy right he was elated he he
elated being
electrocut I don't think I've ever heard
Vader laugh so I wonder what that would
sound like in his mask if he was
chuckling at that
moment um I will admit I only saw two
episodes of the HALO Series was that two
episodes too many oh man
honestly I I wish that I think it wasn't
like I I wish it was front loaded with a
lot more like I feel like the first two
episodes should have been the last two
episodes of the season um I it was all
it was kind of like opened up with like
oh Master Chief doesn't know who he is
he's having an existential crisis you
know like I'm finding myself oh
everything's I'm like can we establish
what the Baseline is first before we get
there you know it's like it's a little
bit too fast too soon cuz cuz even
though I know who Master Chief is I
don't know who he is in this context and
I'm like give it to me from the
beginning who are we you know what are
our ideals so that when he does rip away
from that ideal and goes oh I want my
own little grou and I got to save this
kid um you know like why is that
different has he done this a hundred
times like this before is he always
saving kids you know like like I don't
want him to spell out like I don't know
why I did it like I just
like saying I don't know a 100 times it
didn't really do it for me um uh I think
I was kind of confused by the World
building at some points I felt like it
it didn't read Halo to me it read a
little bit more um like Fifth Element
you know there was some like wacky
costuming and some like just moods that
weren't right for me um you like when he
brought Lady Gaga on and he was like oh
yeah c
hey hey Mari how' you how' you feel when
he when Master Chief was in the the
Lawless civilization not having his
helmet
on I first I wondered would this have
happened if Mandalorian wasn't a
thing yeah I was like I was like did
they write the HALO Series and then
they're like all right we did it guys we
did it boys and girls let's let's print
it on paper and then the Mandalorian
came by and they're like [__]
sorry I'm like they're like it's the
same
story so how are we going to
differentiate ourselves we can't get rid
of the one piece where it's giving him
emotion and humanlike qualities of
wanting to save uh a you know a helpless
being grou or Quan ha um and it's like
all right then let's unmask him um
because clearly that's the one
differentiator and then we all went what
That was supposed to be
me and another thing that like when H
girl had had the gun and he's like it's
not going to hit me it's good this is a
mark helmet and then and then he takes
it off oh now she can hit you that makes
a lot of sense my dude yeah I hated that
scene I know exactly what you're talking
about y I hated that scene I I wanted
him to build he he takes it off because
she's like how can I trust you and and
then he takes the the the helmet off and
I'm like that says everything wrong
about
because go ahead go ahead it's built on
a legacy of trusting this character by
not seeing him as a human being his
human face it's it's having built that
trust over years and years of playing
his games um with him as the tital
character and and it has everything to
do with what's in his heart and not what
the the men you know like the menacing
sort of like thing that we look at from
the outside if anything we come to trust
the menacing thing that come that that
we see on the outside so in order for
her to not trust that rips away
everything that's that built and not to
mention like we say master chief had
enough like thought process enough
intuition that okay I'm just going to
take my helmet off and she's not going
to shoot
me doesn't seem like Master Chief yeah
like why did she earn that like but
anyway but it's my turn I'll get it I I
do want to add one thing to what Mari is
talking about what ad is talking about
and this is the push back this is where
In fairness to the other side that cuz
obviously we are te F to the other side
obviously we are team keep your damn
helmet on right it's not even team keep
your helmet on team like have your
helmet on on situations that make sense
he be having his helmet off every way
like I'd be surprised if he had his
helmet off in space can't bre they let
be know with the poster the poster they
got his face like just in case you
thought it' be
different they they' be super rebellious
with the poster they like you don't like
that so what we still doing it so so
respectfully that they going there might
just get rid of the the helmet at this
point so exactly like he they got him
shooting in the civies you see where
he's in the civies shooting with with no
armor no arm see that that's my issue is
okay if you want to build this emotional
thing that's fine but logically from the
from the from the person we know as
Master Chief in the Hal and I love the
people that said this is their
interpretation well their inter
interpretation sucks like logically from
what we've known of Master Chief
throughout the years his TCT he's a
tactician he's a he's very strategic
he's he's he's extremely like intuition
when it comes to the combat you mean to
tell me he going to fight with no helmet
all just out like that like that makes
no sense I'm with you in fan other side
I just want especially the coven got
Jackal anytime you just get sniped facts
now if this is what they say this is
Pablo sh his an article who plays Mass
chief he said um why explain why Mass
Chief doesn't always wear his helmet he
said you're not going to be able to
bring an audience along in a long form
story without having access to the
character's face which tells you what
they're feeling how they think about
everything the access to a character's
emotional life over the course of time
is what makes you empathize and connect
with the character he said I'm sorry but
having the mask off is is the only
choice for long form storytelling and
television and my contract says as much
that's what I would say to anybody who
dis Pascal Pablo going in Pablo going in
y'all he said I want to say to anybody
who disagrees with that I respect that
opinion but it's a pretty basic place to
start when you're talking about a
television show of quality and the last
thing he says one thing I've learned
early early on is that as many different
opinions in the Halo Universe as there
are Halo fans so obviously you're not
going to be able to please everyone but
I want to say that we are tailoring
tailoring an entertainment experience
that's tailored to the medium that it's
for so he pushing back hard get face and
he get it's fine cuz at the end of the
day I got one thing Last of Us stuck to
lore and made it make sense like it just
I get it people's like oh it's hard to
show emotion there is V for vanana uh
multiple people that's had a mask on the
entire duration of their game uh we were
just talking about Darth Vader obviously
they're not the same one to one but
don't get me this you can't show motion
with that I face out too you can see
emotion emotion on like Final Fantasy
Tactics where there's there's little
Sprites walking around a mat so you me
to told me that they could show emotion
and that with no words just text and
some Sprites walking around the map but
do it I Ren my previous comment I have a
feeling they have not seen the
Mandalorian don't say I'm already going
to say you can't compare it they push
back at us they get
mad I think the double whammy for Halo
fans is like we have come to know Master
Chief's voice so well and trust that
voice that it's like it's it's all of a
sudden saying that the voice is not good
enough right like that we need human
eyebrows and eyeballs to to evoke
emotion when when Halo made us cry
from
go ahead I was going to say like I saw
some people sharing this on Twitter
perfect example uh in Halo infinite when
he was talking to the pilot after the
pilot was you know really down on
himself for abandoning everyone he had a
logical conversation never took his mask
off and there was there was more emotion
in that scene than there was all of the
TV show yeah I think there's something
to say about a mask too it's I think
that okay we're going to get we're going
to get real deep now
like we all wear masks right in our in
our day-to-day lives like different
masks for different situations type of
thing and I think we do that because it
emotionally Keeps Us guarded that way
and I think that a character that keeps
his mask on at all times there is
something that that em evokes emotion
without saying anything at all there is
a inability to open up there's an
inability to say the things that you you
wish that you could say with with the
facial expression that you keep hidden
behind this mask and I think that's what
makes it compelling you you know that
he's going through all of these things
and just the the the the motion of an of
a face going here can say a lot more
than a face
going you know it's
like it's subtlety and I think that that
rather it's the analogy of you feel more
when somebody is te eyed and trying to
get their emotions out than somebody
who's balling and having a crazy cry you
know it's and and I think that we've
lost that
subtlety no fair enough fair enough uh
solve uh your thoughts so like Mari I
think I watched two or three episodes of
the first season I think I stopped when
when he met when he met Cortana is when
I stopped I actually felt a little he
said when it got good
felt like the show got a little bit
better when it come to yeah CU it felt
like it felt like the relationship was a
little bit antagonistic at oh yeah he he
didn't want her at all he thing in his
head what the hell was this thing so
yeah I got to go back and finish it but
um after seeing the trailer right yes I
completely agree about the about the
helmet thing it just it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense you it can be done it
has been done I think it would Elevate
the quality of the show having to you
know figure that out and how to you know
extract emotion from an emotionless
helmet but we like like Mari said I've
cried at many a Halo moment and I'm just
like no it can be done it can absolutely
be done so yeah that's sad that they
going that route I understand that it is
his own thing and and they need to
appeal it have it appeal to a broader
audience which is why these decisions
are made but now I I to me that's what I
liked kind of about the the second
trailer right even though yes it is is
Lady Gaga talking over the trailer about
she's going to bring your ruin at the
end of the day Covenant the Fall Of
Reach I if they handle a Fall Of Reach
properly if they handle the Fall Of
Reach properly I'll be happy I I'll be
happy if at least those lore points are
handled with the care that they deserve
um so I'm excited to see how they've
evolved a little bit and maybe listened
they could they could push back all they
want they have to listen to the
criticism you would be if they mess up
the Fall Of Reach yeah that would be
that would that
would if they mess up the Fall Of
Reach CU because people are very when it
comes to Halo when it comes to lorewise
like the Halo lore heads like the reach
is like the
Pinnacle got a break protocol Jason
Hendrick finds he said during the random
love seen Chief will put the helmet
on yo you wow for that continue
yeah yeah yeah Master cheeks in effect
the master cheeks was out there Master
cheeks clapping cheeks clapping CLA
president of War he felt that was the
thing to do I I'm I'm I'm hopeful for
what they could do with all of reach but
again when you think about it I and I
don't know I don't know the interstitial
stuff with the books yeah when you think
about it how much is Chief actually
involved in that right so you know do
they Midway point through the season is
Chief just out of the picture and
they're focusing on uh I forgot the team
name of the team um that would be
interesting right to sort of Swit shift
the focus from Chief and focus on this
team and really really go you know
follow and suit with with the story I
wonder if Noble Six is going to be in it
that's what I'm talking about yeah Noble
Six yeah that would be that would be
something right and Noble Six obviously
never takes off the helmet and you don't
know who it is yo you know how be crazy
if noble 6 is in it and he's the only
one that don't take
I'm done I'm done I'm done did they say
if Nate Filan is going to be in it is he
going to be part of the team or is he
not going to I don't know if they got
that Nate's budget is
going I know about that I don't know
about that bag I don't know about what
do you think of the people that say this
isn't the game you don't it's
unrealistic to expect a game you know
the lore from the game and this is its
own thing they're they're you it's
adaptation they're doing their own thing
and if you want the game just go play
the game like what do you guys think of
that comments because there's a lot of
them and you guys you got one sitting
right here
they like I said I understand the whole
thing about you having to make it for a
broader audience I understand that and
in that there will be changes but I just
still think also like you said about the
Last of Us The Last of Us stuck pretty
closely to that and they they they
filled in the gaps right for some things
that worked for TV and I think they they
could have taken that same approach with
this and just fill in the gaps and give
us you know and just give us what what
we wanted yeah again I think the biggest
point is the hel because you stopped the
three I stopped the three so I I can't
really say but
okay point it might have been three
episodes too many for me at that point
Mari um I think that it really depends
on um franchises and there's too many
good examples out there to mess this up
at this point you know like I think last
of us is a great one
where Sonic did a good job yeah they
realize they realize where um the fans
are fervent for lore and I think you
can't you can't deviate from the lore
that we know and the things that we like
for certain aspects detective Pikachu is
a fantastic idea of like do whatever you
want man like we have an idea of what
this might be and then do whatever you
want you're not touching a thing that
like a hot you know like like a scar but
something like Halo something like last
of us something that that has evoked
emotion I think that is the thing that
you can't Touch Too Much CU it it is
it's deep rooted in uh players and it's
like I don't know I I think I saw
Witcher in the in the comment section
but like Witcher is something where I
didn't I'm not emotionally tied to it I
I put you know like 500 hours but I'm
not like oh my God my girl has to be
yeah to be
here's my thing like I understand people
like they're trying to BR to a bigger
audience but it's just like people in
the chat are saying you got last of us
that's mad successful uh you know the
Mario movie made like a billion dollars
like Sonic's they're up to the third one
like you can still have lore and still
be accurate to the lore there's a
difference between having be lore
accurate and then the characters don't
even act like the characters from the
game like there's difference between the
two and I I feel like people are like oh
know I honestly truly feel that they
could have did anything to this and that
you could use that excuse for everything
it's an annotation addict you don't you
don't need to stick with the Lord with
temptation like come
on let me get KY I want to get it starts
real quick on this uh the turning off my
mic the
trailer oh man I loved it okay I loved
it only thing I didn't love about uh
season one was Master cheeks that's it
y'all didn't need to have my man butt
cheeks out that was
you know what's quick
called okay okay what
happened no I'm talking after this
though okay knock yourself out it's your
topic but my thing is we had this
conversation last year we had it and for
all y'all grumpy dudes get off my Lord
put your helmet on you
deviant d i talking that much season two
showed up and did well yeah it did
fantastic despite what you
thought and then and then they said yo
for my next
trick y yall like yall like Mas you
ain't like to you ain't like the mask
off this time I'm taking my jacket
off I'm busting shots in the street with
a tank top on
Yo the chief in the C I'm not gonna lie
the worst thing they can do now is have
him lose all his armor and out there
with just a
gun and and it was still selling we get
a season
three for all the people that think they
know how TV
work this ain't games all right and and
listen if y'all mad at anybody be mad at
uh Pedro SC be mad at him that
Mandalorian
crap and then he he has infected
everyone else all right so this it is
what it is if you don't like it do like
everybody else and stop at episode three
but if you like myself that like Star
Trek Star Wars TV shows that are uh
different this is a to me this is a
comic book drawn by not the main artist
and not the main story to me I got you
and I just go in and I just watch it and
have fun now apparently millions of
other people felt the same way and we're
on our way to season two and I'm going
to watch every episode like I watched it
the first one I watch every episode and
then after we finish here I'm going to
rate it high on Rotten Tomatoes again oh
my Lord then we going to go on to season
three where he's going to have a jetpack
with no armor
okay you're the one on Rotten Tomatoes
got we found him we found him we found
where he at yeah we know who it is
explain something to me yes please how's
King GNA talk about this lore this lore
that you know it's just for fun and he's
the same person that be nitpicking every
comic book movie because it don't stick
to law when they don't stick to the law
in MCU oh going let us know oh that's
like Jackman because he ain't the same
oh facts get him get him I can't stand
Hugh Jackman see he Too Tall he too tall
for Wolverine
yeah yeah my my hate a Hugh Jackman
ain't stopp him from being he wear the
suit D Jackman don't wear the suit was
King was protesting he had his picky
face he hates me he hates me Jackson
hates me and you know what's the best
part about it he's back playing
Wolverine and and he's not gonna have
that damn mask on it yeah they respect
the law King let them let Wolverine do
them my get off the law enjoy it it's
just for fun but you know what I did I
watched and I'm going to watch so I got
no choice I'm not there telling him put
on your damn ass you but it's not gonna
happen so again I'm in a position where
either I can be on for the ride or I can
just do like y'all did and say I'm GNA
watch two or three episodes he went from
one side of neutro real fast I respect
it he standing on it he standing on it I
can't stand it I'm I'm going keep it
real but at the same time Daniel says
y'all forget King ofms He's a
hypocrite y'all got to understand that
y'all not going to box me in baby we not
box you we fa look y y'all said all the
points I really needed to say um look to
to regardless of my feelings of hating
the mass situation and my feelings of
them being
overtly aggressive with we're going to
continue this and we know you don't like
it but we're continuing this you know my
whole thing is obviously reaches an
thing I will say this the part I did
like was actually the end when Cortana
took him over when he had to shut up and
wear the mask yeah well hey you got
catch up there's a there's a segment
where it happens and when that happens
wherever that was in season one I
enjoyed I was like yes this is a shut up
and
dribble get in there and do what I like
and and and bring the action to it so I
was fine with that but yeah we'll see we
got to see how they do you know the
whole Au situation and whatever and
shout out to my man K STI reprising his
role as
um my man is in there doing his thing
you thought I wasn't going to get you
I'm going get you brother I saw you in
there you know what say it's good to see
you back we'll see what happens but my
tempering my expectations based on the
show rers
got I was say I got way more excited
when I saw it at reach that's all I was
going to say that's true what do you
think they would would have happened if
they just went full mask on didn't
really say anything about it but season
2 came board and they're like full mask
on do you think that fans would come
back to it or do you think fans would
just be like a little too late I would
they would they complain but they would
they come back here's the thing Mari
like I don't mind his masks off I just
want it to make sense from like him
being in battle like he' just be walking
around literally just sh shots being
fired around mask off like I didn't like
it when he was walking around without
his armor on and he had like the the the
onesie on on had the yes he was walking
around with W in hostle the hostle area
and he got nothing on and everybody know
it's Master Chief he he could be merked
at any minute and I'm like going on it's
too heavy for him he's a super soldier
and he it's too like he's like oh it
gets hot sometimes I didn't like see it
looked like it felt like I was seeing a
man in his gym jams and I'm like we're
not there yet I'm with you that was like
What episode two like episode three and
I'm just like that was episode two dude
episode two I'm with you and this is
that's what Mari I'm so with you to me
no disrespect I just feel was she was
out after that I feel besides the show
Runners Pablo got a little too much
power about what he want to do with this
situation and my thing is look look you
could take it off all I'm just saying
make the situations earned that's all
make it make make they get paid by this
no I get that they not pushing your
character that's but do vad said
different Dar Vader said now Dar Vader
took his face off too we found out he
wasn't black oh my God oh my for a long
time for a long time I
said you gonna see James Jones
J off the they took the mask off I'm a
child in the movie theater I said oh my
God I said darl Vader ain't black he he
a living up to the Darth point I said I
thought Luke was lightskinn yo Mari fell
out the
[Music]
G he comes out people ask him what you
feel about Star Wars man he ain't
black I know James Jones voice and then
when the mask came off I said
oh I've been Boozled dog so so please
please I've been it hurt early long you
already ripped the band off so I'm happy
I'm happy y'all get
this we going move on it happened to me
your turn your turn